gentlemen on your anvils there is a
cloth go ahead and remove that for me
what you have there are Bars of adcrv2
Steel which we want you to use in the
core of a sand my blade sand mine's a
technique that has taken down many a
skilled Smith in this Forge oftentimes
they'll use mild Steel in the
construction but today we're gonna up
the Annie a little bit and the
competition we're calling double trouble
today we want you to wrap your sand Mai
in this
we have bars of 1095 and 15 N20 steel
right here gentlemen that I want you to
make Damascus builds out of you will
then take that Damascus clad it on top
of your adcrv2 constructing a sand my
Damascus blade gentlemen you have three
hours on the clock good luck your time
starts
now
first thing you gotta grab hold of that
Damascus and get it shined up because
the mill scale that's on the pieces of
metal itself that's all impurities and
it will not stick with that on there but
I'm going to use the whole stack so I
can get the layer count
I'm looking at all the steel that they
gave me and I've just decided that that
is way too much and so I'm only going to
do 14 layers I feel that's plenty of
Steel I know I need to be patient and
wait for that steel to come up to
temperature so that I get really good
forage Wells
who
once I get the Billet welded up I just
head right to the forge the first weld
is always the most important so I'm not
going to push this Billet too far if I
go after it too much at one end I can
easily have the other end pop up on me
and I'm not about to do that perfect the
welds look good I'm super happy with it
[Music]
I got my stacks I'm going to set the
welds if this doesn't go right this is
really going to suck
that's a good color looks very even
throughout
that'll do
I definitely feel really good about my
Damascus Billet that it is welded up
solid so I can go ahead and do my sand
my bill enough
shut up when you have your two feet what
you're going to be the cladding material
you want those to be the same width
now that I have the Damascus the
thickness that I want I'm going to cut
it to a nice six inch Pieces Just Like
The Core steel and I'm just going to
weld that back on and do the exact same
thing that I just did with the 1095 and
15 and 20.
I got my stacks and I've got the ADC rv2
I'm going to set the welds on my sand
mine it's less difficult because it's
only three pieces instead of 24 but it's
super critical no issues whatsoever I'm
very happy about that
the Tang is out of good shape with time
running out I know I need to get over to
the forge and start doing my heat treat
so now that the Billet is all forged
welded together I'm just going to start
hammering the tip in yeah Max is
actually using an interesting technique
instead of just cutting a dip in he
rounded the edges so when you start
hammering you don't have those two peaks
that want to come together and stay slip
over the top smart move
I want to get ready for the quench I
want to make very sure that I don't
overheat the tip the tip can overheat
very easily
Chris is in the oil pull my knife out of
the oil I have no big issues all I need
to do is grind it's way too thick
I'm trying to forge in my tip get that
done and then I'm going to start on my
handle I'm looking at the clock right
now I've got to get that quenched on so
I have time to grind it into the perfect
shape
Brian's in the oil
it all worked out the way I wanted it to
the hell with it I'm going over to the
grinder
thank you
Max is in the Quench and pull out the
blade and it's dead straight I'm super
happy with it I know I have a lot of
scale on the outside of it so I have to
start taking this off
five four three two one gentlemen put
down your tools because this round is
over
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
strength test now we're keeping with our
double treble theme we got a two-part
strength test our copper and wood chop
copper likes to bite and grab edges wood
likes to snap blades and wreck handles
so let's see how your Edge holding and
overall construction is going to hold up
Max you're up first how you feeling I
think you're about to void the warranty
[Music]
all right Max good job you survived man
just a couple things right in this
section right here wasn't super sharp
and I can run my finger across it and
you did pick up
couple rolls right here
but otherwise everything's still
straight everything's tight good job
thank you
it's always fun for the second guy Brian
yeah thanks yeah looking forward to it
Jay
[Music]
I'm good
okay Brian she still lives good job with
paracord built up the handle a little
bit more and gave me a good grip
now everything stayed straight and tight
nothing came loose nicely done thank you
all right Chris you're up you ready I'm
ready
oh
[Music]
my God
Christian survived good job thank you
your Edge is fine you got a little bit
of glinting but not much
handles tight handles comfortable
and stayed strong and survived good job
thank you
all right blade Smiths this is the
sharpness test the double the Tommy
matte slice
now unlike the strength test this is all
about how sharp your edges are and how
well they cut these to Tommy mats a
sharp knife should be able to cut
cleanly a jagged one or a dull one well
may rip it or Worse do nothing at all
Max you're up first you ready for this
sure
all right Max let's talk about your
weapon here it cut
almost all the way through just this
area right here where you have some
rolling actually kind of ripped on that
the Tommy mat overall sir your weapon
you will cut thank you
Brian are you ready you know tear her up
you mad dog all right will do
foreign
your Edge is razor sharp enough to cut
through both mats overall sir your
weapon you look up outstanding
Chris your turns are you ready yes sir
all right Chris on the first time we met
although it didn't cut all the way
through it's a longer cut with the angle
I was cutting at with your blade and the
second one cut all the way through
but we're all sir your weapon you look
good awesome
well gentlemen all three of you turned
in fantastic Blaze but in this double
trouble competition only two can move
forward and the blade Smith leaving the
forges
unfortunately blade's not making the cut
today
Doug's going to tell you why Max your
blade took some dulling during the
strength test and it affected its
performance during the sharpness test
for that reason for letting you go
totally understand
well Max it was awesome watching your
work you absolutely know what you're
doing you have what it takes to fight in
the Forge time here has ended I'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
fourth floor well thank you good luck
guys after testing I news me honestly I
was just happy to get past the first
round so the fact that I made it through
the second I couldn't be happier that
the whole Journey's been amazing really
it's just it's something I don't do
every day so it was just a fun challenge